all right new this morning the bite
administration is turning up the heat in
the battle to protect abortion rights
ahead of a upcoming supreme court ruling
so let's get straight to ed o'keefe at
the white house for us ed good morning
tony good morning the bite
administration as you said is vowing to
continue to fight for abortion rights as
the supreme court's decision on the
issue nears and today vice president
harris is set to meet with doctors and
nurses who treat those seeking the
procedures she set to meet virtually
this afternoon with abortion providers
largely working in states with some of
the most restrictive abortion laws would
have have those so-called trigger laws
that would immediately ban or greatly
restrict abortion access if roe vs wade
is overturned by the court as is now
expected the white house is trying to
keep this issue in focus as election
season continues and as we await a final
ruling the u.s marshals are now helping
provide protection to supreme court
justices and their families amid
concerns about threats to them
gail
i see they're mowing the grass at the
white house this morning or we could
hear you
once again once again thank you you paid
for that
taxpayer fund
money well spent money well thank you ed